une scène traditionnelle qui n'aura pas
lieu cette année en raison de l'épidémie
de kovy de 19
exceptionnellement les examens de
l'éducation nationale seront évalués sur
le mode du contrôle continu
il n'y aura donc pas d'épreuves du
baccalauréat en juin prochain
seule solution pratique pour cette année
s'il s'agit bien encore une fois d'une
solution a prise à titre exceptionnel
d'un s'est laissé le contrôle continu
dans l'état actuel des choses il n'était
pas possible en ce cas qui soit possible
d'organiser le bac normalement
l'autoroute est habituel que va prendre
en compte le contrôle continu
les résultats obtenus lors des deux
premiers trimestres ainsi que les notes
obtenues en jouant en cas de
déconfinement les professeurs mettront
également une appréciation sur le
travail fourni pendant la période de
confinement appréciation qui sera prise
en compte par un jury de notation qui
évaluera l'assiduité le comportement de
chaque élève
une mesure qui pourrait impliquer des
inégalités selon certains syndicats
enseignants et que quand on rencontre
nous on a des fortes inégalités selon
selon les différents établissements les
pratiques d'évaluation
le voilà l'état d'étude des locales donc
effectivement il y aura du jury et nous
on a fait pour que la transparence au
fonctionnement de ces jolies les oraux
sauront-ils maintenue pour le bac les
quelques soixante et onze mille élèves
yvelinois pourront passer un oral de
rattrapage début juillet si elles
obtiennent une moyenne comprise entre 8
et 9,9 sur 20 concernant les épreuves
anticipées de français en première les
cris est annulé mais l'épreuve orale
devrait bel et bien être maintenus fin
juin ou début juillet